[Music]
Rutherford's atomic model was quite
commendable when it came to explaining
the structure of atoms however it was
not very appropriate theoretically and
why are we saying so we know that any
charged object which revolves in a
circular motion gains acceleration
gradually similarly if the electron is
moving fast in a circular path then it
will also gain acceleration and on
gaining acceleration it's bound to
liberate energy in some form now if it
continuously keeps radiating energy then
ultimately all the energy of the
electron will get over and it will fall
into the nucleus this would result in
high instability of the atom but wait a
second all these things do not happen in
an atom and how do we know this because
in nature all the atoms are stable that
means the hypothesis put forth by
Rutherford was also incorrect not really
the hypothesis just needed slight
modifications these were made by the
next legendary scientist in our list
called Niels Bohr he made a few
additional explanations to describe the
atomic structure the postulates put
forward by Niels Bohr were as follows
firstly only certain special orbits
called discrete orbits of electrons are
allowed inside the atom secondly while
revolving in these discrete orbits the
electrons do not radiate energy now
these points definitely tell us why an
atom is so stable but what exactly are
these paths or orbits in which the
electrons revolve around the nucleus
let's understand with an example do you
know how our solar system is yes it
appears somewhat like this now here the
Sun is stationary at the center while
the planets revolve around it but have
you noticed that the planets always
revolve in fixed paths we never find any
planet jumping to a different path all
of a sudden right they always encircle
this
in to find parts in a similar way we
have the atomic structure the nucleus
acts like the Sun located at the center
and the electrons are like planets which
revolve in fixed defined orbitals these
electron orbitals are referred to as
shells or energy levels now the name
energy levels gets us to an important
concept Niels Bohr suggested that the
electrons revolving in these orbitals do
not radiate energy now this is justified
when we use the term energy levels
because it indicates that each shell has
got a defined energy level that means
when the electrons revolve in these
shells they do not liberate any form of
energy and how do we name these shells
to indicate their position it's simple
beginning from the one near the nucleus
we name them as the Keysha
l shell m shell and shell and so on yes
k L M and so on and what if we want to
number them in that case we use the
letter n in lowercase and write them as
N equals 1 N equals 2 N equals 3 and so
on beginning from the one next to the
nucleus so we can name them
alphabetically or we can even number
them v all these theories and points
known do we now know the structure of a
typical atom completely the nucleus
contains positive protons and the
electrons revolving around in fixed
orbitals is that how an atom is
structured not really we still have one
more subatomic particle left and what
and where could it be
let's find that out it was around the
year 1932 when a famous English
physicist Sir James Chadwick found the
third subatomic particle he found that
the particle had a mass almost
equivalent to that of the proton and
what about its charge astonishingly it
had no charge yes the particle was
neutral the particle was later named as
Neutron denoted by the letter n does now
we have the complete design
of an atom in the center lies the
nucleus having positively charged
protons and neutral neutrons while the
negatively charged electrons revolved in
fixed orbitals around the nucleus but
how exactly are the electrons
distributed in the respective orbitals
is there a way to find out the maximum
number of electrons that one orbital can
contain or is it that the electrons are
randomly scattered in the orbitals let's
find out the answers to these questions
in our upcoming video
[Music]
you